good afternoon ladies and gentlemen for
those of you who have just arrived we
are in we're actually through half of
our program and we begin the afternoon
session with a keynote speech by
professors big names in ski who in this
crowd doesn't need much of an
introduction but I feel compelled to
make a few remarks in any case because
for many many years professor Kaczynski
taught in this building and had his
office just two floors below us so he is
a storehouse of memories so to speak
when it comes to events and people who
have come through Columbia University
and had something to do with world
politics as I understand it today our
distinguished guest is going to be
speaking not so much about Poland but
the context in which Polish foreign
policy is made and that's something that
we are reminded of almost on a daily
basis when we pick up the paper or turn
on our computers and find out what this
government or that government is doing
in the world and then begin to wonder
how is the new Polish government going
to react to this as most of you know the
government of Poland was just voted in a
week or so ago and so its foreign policy
options are sort of on the table that's
another reason why listening to a
specialist like dr. Brzezinski is
important because it sets the tone for
understanding what may or may not happen
in in Warsaw I don't want to give his
speech for him because of course I can't
and I don't want to take up any of his
time in your time I will say that it
will probably be a speech on the shorter
side and dr. Brzezinski will be happy to
take questions from the audience so let
me please ask our guests to to speak
professor Minsky ladies and gentlemen
first of all let me say how nice it is
to be back here in this building at
Columbia I haven't been in this building
for 20 years in fact I haven't been at
Clark University for 20 years so it's
quite a homecoming for me Columbia was a
major milestone in my academic career
but in some respects more importantly at
least to me it was also the springboard
for my non academic or perhaps one can
even call it political career so I have
many associations with Columbia that I
treasure I'm also delighted to be
participating in this conference which
addresses an important and timely issue
because Poland is not only a gain
independent but because it is
independent it has that a foreign policy
Poland is a player on the European scene
and through Europe and through the ocean
poland can contribute in some measure to
the kind of world we live in so it is
timely to reflect historically on
Poland's foreign policy but also to
think as I would like to do out loud
about the implications for Poland of its
own changing in geopolitical context and
in reference to that broad subject I
proposed to address essentially three
broad issues the first involves the
proposition that historically for Poland
its current geopolitical context and I
have said this before and I'm sure it's
not a revelation to anyone but it is
worth repeating Poland enjoys the best
geopolitical context in its entire
history it is the best ever it has never
been as good as it is today it one
considers Poland's history porns
geography and poland's experience to the
west of poland there is something that's
being called Europe and it is not only a
geographical designation nor is it only
a cultural designation it has
significant political overtones even if
not carried the ultimate logical
conclusion there is a Europe politically
in the process of being shaped and there
certainly an economic Union financial
union that is an ongoing reality that
has never existed in the same fashion
before and particularly with the kind of
self-definition that that your own has
there was the Holy Roman Empire ones to
the west of Poland but the Holy Roman
Empire wasn't very holy and wasn't very
Roman but it was an empire and had some
of the Imperial attributes that empires
have so that wasn't such a felicitous
experience in that respect what there is
today to the west of Poland is truly new
and it's truly good that is to say a
Europe committed to the notion of
transnational cooperation committed to
the idea of a European role in the world
that involves the propagation as well as
institutionalization of certain basic
values a Europe which doesn't Harbor
Imperial aspirations Europe which if
anything is perhaps too pacifist rather
than anything else and in that context
it is also important to recognize that
the west of Poland a process of truly
significant and historically almost
unprecedented polish German
reconciliation has been underway now for
a number of years it has had its absence
has its downs but the basic trend is
certainly one of reconciliations it has
many symbolic expressions but has also
many tangible realities and the
commingling of the two nations is taking
place and that respect the situation to
the west is really an extremely
favorable extremely favorable to Poland
to an unprecedented historical degree
moreover within that Europe Poland
entertains legitimate aspirations to be
one of the more important players in the
community or union of 25 fallen certain
legitimately can claim to be one of the
top six and while that is not a
formalized reality it is nonetheless a
latent reality a latent reality which by
virtue of being a reality even if latent
has political significance so the
situation geopolitical in that respect
is favorable but let us look at these
when did Poland have a better situation
in the East then it has today Russian
borders are roughly the same as those of
Ivan the Terrible Russia has moved back
several hundred years there is a sort of
buffer state between Poland and Russia a
buffer state as vulnerable whose future
is uncertain but it is there nonetheless
Belarus and it is an open issue whether
it will continue or not but even if it
doesn't continue it is fair to assume
that the notion of nationalism has also
begun to affect the attitudes of younger
by the Russians
and the process of read i Jes ting
Belarus by Russia should it occur it's
not going to be on that simple so in
that respect pollen situation is more
favorable but even more important of
course is the fact that there is an
independent Ukraine president fresh
nevsky in a sentence which I'm sure he
deeply regrets saying but which was
quite accurate said that of course he
likes Russia but he likes a Russia
without Ukraine even better and I think
in that respect he voiced the sentiment
of many Poles of most voles and of
course is not an accident that this
innocent sounding sentence so strongly
offended his neighbor to the east but in
able to the east was far more distant
far weaker far more uncertain of his own
future it is a neighbor that for the
first time in its history is truly a
national state but a national state with
serious demographic problems when Russia
became a separate Federation at 151
million people today as 144 the
demographic dropped is serious its
far-reaching there are some indications
it may be accelerating of the hundred
and forty-three million or so citizens
of the Russian Federation on 116 million
Russians of their remaining 30 or so
million 20 million or Muslims at a time
of intensifying Muslim political
identity so Russia has serious problems
Russia has serious internal problems
which do place a question mark regarding
its future role and certainly very much
change its ability to affect polish
history the way Russia did affect polish
history over the last several hundred
years affected it in a very decisive
which proponent also meant the
progressive loss of Independence and
then still looking at this favorable
geopolitical situation across the ocean
the United States to which Poland is
actually allied and that United States
today is the only superpower in the
world that relationship between Poland
and America gives Polish foreign policy
a transatlantic dimension which it never
really had before to be sure an American
president once said that Poland is the
conscience of the world but it was one
of those nice sayings that occasionally
I said to polish visitors but without
much strategic substance today there is
some strategic substance that has not
exaggerated but there is some strategic
suckoids to the relationship between the
United States and Poland and that too
gives Poland a wider sense of its place
in the world and a more favorable
geopolitical setting indeed the
combination of an EU to the west and of
the u.s. across the ocean means that
Poland is associated in an unprecedented
fashion with the dominant force in the
world the dominant potential force for
good and is an integral part of the zone
of peace so that is the political
context and it is remarkably favorable
but and this is the second part of my
presentation watch out but watch out
for if we look more closely at the West
we also see something else some loss of
momentum in the process of European
unification some potential significant
indeed slowing down in the process of
the expansion of Europe Europe confronts
some very serious uncertainties the
process of unification which are so
transformed the political culture and
the political mission the political
identity of Europe is slowing down it is
not being reversed yet and one shouldn't
hasten to overly pessimistic conclusions
but some uncertainties do appear in the
scene that unity which the name
symbolizes european union is no longer
so strong indeed one of the paradoxes of
the present situation is that the
European Union named European Union
follow the European community whereas in
fact it should have been the other way
around the European Union existed much
more prior to nineteen ninety one and
today the European Union is much more
European community because prior to
nineteen ninety one there was a real
basis for political union in a divided
Europe in a divided Europe it was easier
to speak of political union involving
France and some other Western European
countries and half of Germany half of
Germany not all of Germany much easier
to think of Union in that context and of
Britain more comfortably associated with
it because such a Europe would not
necessarily detach itself from the ally
across the Atlantic and such a Europe
could comfortably be controlled
symbolically more than a reality by the
franco-german leader
and practice much more by more subtle
British French German interrelationship
by that European Union now is a European
community of 25 in which national
interests are surfacing in which the
sense of momentum towards intensified
political unification a slowdown in
which there are temptations as well as
opportunities for asserting the national
interest over the common interest and of
course one sees that from a standpoint
of Poland most dramatically in the
German Russian relationship it is of
course not a relationship directed
against Poland a son in an exaggerated
fashion proclaim but it is a
relationship based on a more explicit
affirmation of respective German and
Russian interests to a degree that was
not the case 15 years ago when in
reality the European Union preceded the
European Community at that time there
was much more than inclination to think
geopolitical of transcendental
continental interests symbolized by the
European Union of Western Europe today
national interests and surface and they
can surface with greater intensity and
sometimes with some adverse consequences
for the national interests of others and
the poles are naturally concerned about
the implications of some aspects of
German Russian relations that have
manifested themselves in the course of
the last several years and that in turn
is associated with some degree of
resurgence of genuine nationalist
priorities nationalist mounted in the
pejorative meaning of the word but
simply descriptively descriptively
national interest nationalistic Lee
defined and that is becoming a more
pervasive phenomenon and in that context
of course
the national interest of Poland may not
ranked the highest because Poland is not
a leading the leading or one of the top
leading European states there are others
were more influential who are richer and
who may have interests that they can
pursue more effectively bilaterally even
at some indirect costs to their
neighbors the situation in the West is
further complicated by the clearly
increased distance across the Atlantic
the Atlantic has become wider it has
become deeper it is no longer so easily
spend there's no doubt that the last
several years have seen a significant
deterioration in the mutual American
European perceptions and attitudes the
way the United States defines its global
interests increasingly diverges from the
way most Europeans define Europe's
global interests this is a question of
strategy in part this is a question of
methods in part this is a question of
values in part and all of that differs
significantly from what existed that are
say 10 years ago and that has
consequences because it means that there
is no automaticity or identity of
European and American perspectives in
the world insofar as Poland is concerned
it creates a situation in which
sometimes choices and sometimes very
painful choices have to be made so in
that sense a situation that the West is
now more complex less so clear-cut there
are some dangerous it doesn't alter the
basic diagnosis the context is good and
better than ever but they are now some
warning signals insofar as they were
is concerned and if the United States
for example gets more deeply involved in
a conflict with Islam the chances are
the de fissures in the American European
relationship will grow wider if the
United States embarks on a political
self-definition in which Islamophobic
language becomes increasingly the
official language of the United States
including of its president the chances
are that more and more Europeans will
take their distance and that will begin
even more deeply to affect the
homogeneity of the West its strategic
shared sense of purpose and complicate
the situation for point and that aspect
is further complicated by some
developments in Poland one census as one
looks at Poland from afar but with some
degree of historical and personal
identification an inclination towards
intensifying parochialism I would
certainly not call it nationalism or
chauvinism but it is a kind of assertive
parochialism that increasingly dominates
the Polish political discourse the
Polish view of the world a sense of
self-righteousness a tendency towards
some extreme language in dealing with
one's neighbors an inclination to assume
the worst about the motives of others
even of what the others do may not be
all that favorable but not necessarily
but as evil as described to call a
pipeline the equivalent of the
Ribbentrop Molotov pact is to me
somewhat of an overstatement to put it
mildly and that effects also Holland's
place in Europe and the way Poland is
perceived in your
some of the same is manifesting itself
even in Polish attitude towards the
eastern neighbors president wash nevsky
slang which was delicate even though
offensive to the excessively sensitive
Russians but some of the language used
by others is less delicate and it has
had the effect may be unfairly may be
altogether unfairly but not undamaged in
leaf or Poland for Poland to be viewed
increasingly as motivated by Russell
phobia and that diminishes the
significance of the Polish voice in
Europe Poland has a natural role to play
as the lead voice in the articulation of
the European quote unquote union's
policy towards the east but the ability
to do that and for that voice to be
respected is diminished if it is assumed
that it is driven by Russell phobic
instincts to be sure again many in the
Kremlin are delivered to propagating
that message and are interpreting any
criticism of Russia even the most
justified as an expression of rasa
phobia but it is part of political
wisdom to be aware of how others might
use one's own language and one's own
posture and to operate in a way that
anticipates and deflects that and I'm
not sure that everything that has
recently transpired in Poland has been
sufficiently responsive to that geo
political imperative but most important
to me is somehow or other the sense in
Europe the Poland is sliding in an
attitude of a domestic parochialism so
deeply rooted in its national
Catholic traditions that it begins to
create a gap between Poland and Europe
that too may be an unfair judgement but
it is important to poles be aware of it
because there is such a thing as a
pathology of words and words do have
effect and one has to be sensitive to it
and that is related to a third aspect
which makes me inclined to say that one
has to be alert and vigilant regarding
the favorable geopolitical context and
that is actual developments in these
I've already alluded to the fact that
Belarus may be swallowed up it may not
be easily digested as in the past but
that's not really a great consolation
the digestion may be more difficult but
the fact of the digestion will still
have Jewish strategic consequences
fertil mean that Russia's borders are no
longer those of Ivan the Terrible it
will mean these will be the borders of
Russia roughly lows of 1941 at least in
the north eastern areas of Poland
Ukraine list will be independent and
that could even lead to more serious
risk which it is difficult to discuss
without being misunderstood and which
nonetheless calls for being loaded
namely that while Europe today is a zone
of peace it is a partial zone of peace
the parts of Europe in which there has
been violence the parts of Europe in
which there is violence there parts of
Europe in which there could be violence
some parts of Europe in which there has
been violence are actually west of
Poland Slovenia Croatia
some parts of Europe in which there is
violence are east of Poland particularly
in the Caucasus to lesser extent in
Moldova there could be violence directly
support in Belarus especially if the
process of digestion was not smooth if
national issues complicated it and that
could all of a sudden put on the agenda
something which many of us have assumed
is now past history the question of
security the question of even military
vulnerability imagine a situation in
which the process of Belarus's
absorption or digestion is not peaceful
not only difficult but actually produces
some conflicts suppose on the Polish
Belarusian frontier there are major
instabilities conflicts they erupt very
suddenly look at friends suppose the
border is breached by thousands then
tens of thousands of refugees suppose
some form of violence erupts
supposable a Russian army is engaged or
an army ostensibly in Belarusian
uniforms but not really rush but not
really better Russian it's awfully close
to the capital of Poland it's very close
to that frontier it's incidentally a
largely undefended capital with very
small garrison and with a large airfield
one can visit a scenario in which all of
its sudden there's conflict and of
course one will say well but Poland is a
member of NATO yes but suppose that
conflict is politically ambiguous
suppose that conflict doesn't clearly
define who is the aggressor and who was
the defender suppose that conflict
creates a situation in which there is a
cross-current of accusations as to
started it and was pursuing it and
suppose in the process nonetheless the
conflict escalates but remains
politically ambiguous I raised that
issue once with a group of Polish
military strategists and the first
reaction reminded me absolutely of 1939
Poland is a member of NATO just as in
1939 Polish military said we have an
alliance with France and Great Britain
and they're obligated to start military
hostilities offensively against Nazi
Germany two weeks after the attack
component took much longer than that to
five years in suppose the conflict is
politically ambiguous what happens then
in a situation in which Poland strategic
planning and defense strategy is very
much dependent on integration into an
alliance system
but the conflict is ambiguous what then
are the strategic implications of
everything that I have said which is my
concluding part with respect to the last
since that is the freshest in your minds
let me simply suggest that in addition
to complete loyal and devoted
integration into NATO alliance Poland's
should have a modest I repeat a modest
nationally autonomous defence capability
capable of sustaining itself for a
sufficiently long period of time so that
an ambiguous war begins to be defined in
the political mind of the West as a war
of aggression justifying indeed
compelling the collective nato response
how long should that capability last
it's very hard to judge but I would say
something in the range of two to three
weeks minimum but two to three weeks of
the capability to defend particularly
the political centers Authority and
military command and control preferable
including the capital that Poland today
does not have it literally does not have
that because in years past his entire
military integration was of course
oriented towards aware war directed at
the West in recent years it has been
reintegrated into a larger native
structure but without any thought given
to a really serious independent
autonomous capability for a solitary
military undertaking that pollen should
have because it'll take a few weeks
before Western public opinion begins to
understand what is at stake I was once
having lunch with President hable my
wife was with me it was the two of us
she's of czech origin we
shani palace and during the lunch hallo
said to me tell me dr. Burzynski if the
Russians attack us will you in America
common defenders this isn't ixora and I
said to him excuse me mr. president but
if you don't mind that really is the
wrong question the real question is if
the Russians attack you will you defend
yourselves if I'm going to scrap that
text completely I would like you to come
in with me and what I'm going to do is
I'm going to put the tape record in
front of you and I'm going to ask you
the very same question I asked right now
and please answer it exactly the same
way and then now make my speech and we
did that and of course his speech took
off and what I said and he said we
should have done that in 1938 and who
knows what history might have been we
should have done this 1948 when the
check on his party was trying to seize
power and who knows what might have been
history we should have done this 1968 so
my first point about the strategic
implications is yes good geopolitical
context best ever but some autonomous
capability for dealing with
unpredictable circumstances which may
not be clear-cut is an essential element
of prudent planning in a favorable
geopolitical setting my second point
regarding strategic implications is that
given what I have said about what is
happening in Europe but also what is
happening in Poland itself renewed
emphasis has to be put on a priority
basis on a revitalization of german
polish reconciliation that is absolutely
the scenic or none of poland's favorable
geopolitical context this has to be
emphasized
this has to be pursued I would like to
see the president-elect like a change
scheme proposed immediately a person
meeting one-on-one with angle America
the German Chancellor and there is an
obvious setting for it the German Polish
university in Frankfurt I'm Odin right
across from the Polish city of sbisa on
the 60 kilometers from Berlin a little
further from Warsaw with the
president-elect can travel extra it's
worth it I think revitalization of the
German Polish relationship is absolutely
critical and far more important then
polish French friendship or polish
British relations this is in the
immediate interest opponent because that
will immediately relate Poland again to
the larger European adventure which
while perhaps stumbling and hiccuping
still remains in number one game in
Europe namely will there be a Europe and
if there is to be your observing is the
engine German is to keep their concern
the Polish reconciliation is of central
importance of sin changing Poland's
image from an increasingly parochial
inward oriented excessively Catholic and
nationalist country that maybe not even
truly European as a result in that
context we should also expect and hope
that the poles will make the enlargement
of NATO to Ukraine not a primarily
polish project or a polish lithuanian
project noble as it is but particularly
the polish German and British project
because the British actually favored a
larger Europe for other reasons
unrelated to the issue of Poland but so
happens that that fits into what I
consider to be an intelligent polar
strategy namely that the inclusion of
Ukraine should be
something that's pursued actively not
just by Poland or even Poland in the
forefront but Germany and Britain and
Poland and then last but not least
Poland should strive to promote a
European foreign policy that speaks to
some degree authentically for Europe and
not for individual European states and
to the extent that Poland is one of the
six more important European nations I
think Poland is in a position to
encourage the emergence of the European
voice that views America as a partner
not as an opponent but also as a partner
that has to listen seriously to what
Europe has to say because one of the
reasons for the current divergence
between Europe and America is that
America has had little reason to listen
to Europe because there was no Europe
talking to America there was a British
prime minister who is eager to be
America's primary first and only partner
who occasionally whispered good advice
but publicly endorsed anything we did
with the consequence that we pocketed
his whispering and took advantage of his
public support but ignored basically
what he was advising a Europe that
speaks with six common voices united
into one not easy to achieve he'll take
time to cultivate would be a Europe that
America would have to listen to more
seriously and that would have the effect
or restoring the American European
partnership because only by acting
together can America and Europe deal
with the problems of the world only by
acting together are we likely to avoid
stumbling into individual difficulties
which for us here in America may mean an
increasing intensifying war with the
world of Islam as a whole and for Europe
a revival
of European nationalist aspirations
inimical to the prospects of united
Europe so in brief and in final
conclusion the challenge of Poland faces
is to take advantage of its very
favorable political context but to take
advantage of it in a deliberate
strategically minded fashion that
reinvigorates that favorable
geopolitical context thank
we have time for a few questions
professor system pillow ruse is the
potential zonal instability are you
really convinced that Ukraine is stable
enough and well enough anchored into the
community and state and not likely again
to be the subject of invention you'd
agree that Ukraine would not also be a
zone my sense is that in spite of all
the ambiguities and uncertainties in
Ukraine including the linguistic
differences which I think are
exaggerated actually there is now in the
predominant sense a Ukrainian political
identity and I haven't struck for
example when I traveled get the troughs
done yet in those regions where
everybody after greeting me officially
in Ukrainian would speak Russian that in
the end the basic message was that after
a decade and a half of Independence we
prefer to have the opportunity to steal
on our own via Kieth and not have to do
it via muscat and to share it with
people from us though but if there is
corruption it's our corruption and we
prefer that that there is now a
statehood with which we identify
ourselves for better or for worse and of
course in november of last year also
showed that there is momentum for better
particularly the younger generation i
think the younger generation takes the
ukraine and political reality for
granted this is not to say that the
political parties are stabilized are not
their fluid their personal this is not
to say that the political system is not
corrupt it's pervasively corrupt as part
of the soviet ethic but not unique in
that respect but there is a
sense that the statehood is a reality
that is subjectively valued and I don't
think the Russians can reverse that also
an additional reason why I don't think
the Russians can reverse that is that
Russia your name and big us an
ambivalent fashion is becoming more
nationalistic in a genuinely Russian
sense ruski not rosy Anene brewski and
you see this in the political discourse
in the political literature in the
manifestations and if that continues is
I think it will because that is the news
source of integration within Russia that
makes it more difficult to swallow other
countries it's easier to swallow other
countries if you have some transnational
doctrine with which you can mask your
imperial ambitions what is the third
Rome or the center of world communism is
much easier to do that in terms of a
super national identity it's hard to
impress people on the basis of
nationalism the poles learned that
themselves in oppressing the Ukrainians
in interwar Poland and because they
didn't have a transnational ideology
anymore they you know the judge post
paleta of three nations it was a
national Poland I was trying to pollen
eyes the Ukrainians and that's why I
didn't work I don't know the Russians
can can regain Ukraine anymore Belarus
is more ambiguous because i think the
much larger degree the population still
does not have a genuine sense of
identification with a separate state but
the younger people do increasingly and
then there are serious national problems
in belarus including a large polish
minority which could produce this
ambiguous scenario on the border and at
some point it could be source of
difficulty
mr. stupid thing is my biggest challenge
facing our boys diplomacy in work today
once we ever come close
well I don't think one can talk of a
single one challenge any country of
almost 40 people has number of
challenges but I spoke about the ones
that are going to be preoccupied Poland
for some time to come and I don't think
they're going to be overcome that
quickly thereby permitting one to start
speculating of challenges beyond the
ones i've mentioned because the ones
that i've mentioned are going to be
engaging poland for quite a while yet
when the rules
require their own their own and
autonomous defense strategy
how did you see the squaring with the
professed gold part of the EU
insecurity indefensible
well first of all I was not advocating
it for other Central European states as
you said I was advocating it
specifically for Poland because Poland
specifically may have that problem and
also point has the potential capability
of being able to respond to the problem
when its own because it is a country 40
million people which doesn't need to be
totally protectorate especially if it's
not in its interest to be a protectorate
and I don't think it is because
protectorates necessarily are less
sovereign then is desirable and in this
area I think sovereignty does dictate a
capability to pursue one's own national
security policy in a manner that
defenseman's interests which could be
placed in jeopardy as I said repeatedly
in a problematically politically
ambiguous situation and that means a
limited capability not not a defense
policy totally preoccupied with our
issue but a limited capability which
ensures certain minima for political
reasons now how is that compatible with
Europeans defense policy theoretically
it isn't but practically it is because
there is no European defense policy
preservation ski about 15 years ago I
heard you speak at Yale to abolish
Institute and he said Poland was in its
best geopolitical
about 300 years today spandy des moulins
entire history and I've been speculating
what makes the change I assumed
membership in NATO was one thing
membership in the European Union
well I don't know what's really is
important is Europe Europe is changing
and that is a very important process
underway whether it's 300 years or six
hundred years doesn't really make much
difference the best ever historically
they simply it certainly wasn't better
plus 300 years ago so that's the point
identify yourself
can pick up a bit and
as such there was a point in science see
available but we see
out of the political
states
in fact networks so you said
well I try to illustrate that in two
ways one first of all in the narrower
sense by pursuing German boys
reconciliation because without that
there's going to be no Poland in Europe
yeah there may be Europe but Poland's
not gonna be in it so that is absolutely
scenic went on but through that some
progressive movement towards
articulation of the European perspective
on some of the larger issues of the
world today including those that affect
America and the American European
relationship there hasn't been a serious
strategic discussion across the Atlantic
involving the large issues today that
confront America and Europe for number
of years there have been dialogues
separately individually with the British
in the dialogue with Pashkov scheme
which perhaps the poles think is of the
same importance as the American British
dialogue but sadly it is not a and the
fact is that there's been a breakdown
essential in any strategic discourse
between American France and under
shredder American Germany Poland as one
of the six countries with a kind of
wider interest than its own immediate
frontiers I think could be engaged in
the process of trying to stimulate that
European dialogue but I begin again to
repeat what I said particularly through
German Polish reconciliation and we
can't do that we have a Poland that
takes stands define through such
wonderful slogans which are testimonial
to polish political wisdom as a nice or
death which you know gave everybody in
Europe a very short lesson in polar
strategic wisdom
not to Poland's benefit so there are
some sort of very obvious lessons to be
learned from even their recent
experience and if there is no American
European dialogue I think the chances
are that American Europe may increasing
to go in different directions America to
its own discomfort in my judgment but
also probably at the cost of reviving
intra-european priority on national
interest and Poland is not so strong as
to be able to benefit from that by the
country what
yeah but pulling is not Russia and I'm
talking about Poland's interests Russia
of course has different interest you
know we have last two questions here and
here you first dr. previously my name is
Marcus track and I know from anecdotally
that many engineers and mathematicians
from Poland worked in Iraq in seventies
do you see any role in Poland's about
mediating what happens in Iraq to do its
historical legacy there mediating the
receiving a different or that rollin
with the US well it is true that polish
engineers and others worked in Iraq but
that does not create the basis you know
for any significant mediation as such
and that was the exploitation of a
particular economic interest which was
beneficial to Poland I suppose was
beneficial to Iraq also but it didn't
endow Poland with any unique
understanding of the Iraqi circumstances
or with an unique ability to influence
events in Iraq I think Poland given the
divisions between Europe and America had
to make a choice and while I am a critic
of the US policy towards Iran and some
of you may know that I am a fairly
outspoken critic of US policy towards
Iraq if I had been in charge of Poland's
foreign policy I would have supported
the United States the cause of reasons
of overall in assessment of Bones
interest in a divided Europe because in
a divided Europe then clearly
identifying Poland with the United
States ultimately is in Poland's
interest but the real opportunity for
mediation
they can only come if there is a serious
Europe that forges European perspective
on the basis primarily of a dialogue
among those European countries that have
some foreign policy interests beyond
their immediate concerns and basically
their sex they happen to be the largest
European countries Britain with a kind
of a global perspective closely United
in its only interests with America but
global nonetheless but European at the
same time France still with a kind of
sense of its own ground air and mission
sometimes exaggerated but nonetheless
with some historical validity Germany
because of its obvious capacity ability
power militarily as well as economically
Italy particularly in terms of the
Mediterranean Spain in terms of North
Africa Poland in terms of the East but
through Europe and not in terms of
traditional polish animosities if those
six countries could gradually begin to
forge what might be viewed as a European
global perspective or even a european
regional perspective then I think the
United States would have to listen and
they could mediate in some sense they
could mediate in the sense of perhaps
diluting this in my view increasingly
black and white almost Manichean
American vision of what is happening in
the Middle East in which it's good guys
versus bad guys forces of freedom versus
forces of hatred or other slogans which
in this fashion define what is a very
complex reality but the reality which
mishandled has ended the potential of
producing very damaging and very
consequential in negative consequence
for America's position in the world
which derivative they will adversely
affect Europe and if Europe is adversely
affected so we'll be pulled my name is
John truck what internal political
forces in Holland might inhibit
hellmann's new Minister of Defence Radek
Sikorski from acting to create an
autonomous defence force to defend the
case of diversion coming from Belarus
well first of all something like that
cannot be created by one individual no
matter how energetic or able and I've
discussed these issues with him
instantly in but it takes more than the
defense minister it takes the government
takes the budget and it takes a serious
military effort it takes also a mindset
and because mindsets are ultimately are
the defining framework for decisions and
you work yourself into a mindset in
which your national security in its
totality is subordinated to the notion
of integration into an alliance system
which is viewed as the source of
foolproof security then it's hard to
begin to think of options and ways of
responding outside of that mindset so
even that is needed but I think there
are people in Poland were not unaware of
what I was saying in fact a couple of
years ago I got an honorary degree from
the Polish national defence academy and
I raised that issue and what was
striking to me was the very diverse
reaction I got from people some senior
officers were absolutely shocked and
stunned and you know kind of saying this
is absolutely
well out of their mindset so to speak in
and the Alliance guarantees everything
some younger officers who have been
getting some thought for example to the
use of territorial defense forces for
transitional role had a different view
so there are people who know that
security involves many dimensions and
many levels and one has to be able to
operate on several at the same time even
if the primary emphasis correctly is an
alliance integration and Alliance
interoperability and alliance
interdependence those are overall
strategically sound principles but they
should not be exclusionary they should
not override some very specific
hopefully historically transitional
aspects of Poland security situation
which should be anticipated and planned
for as well as a vision to thank you
very much
20 years for this retarded visit let's
hope that your next visit won't be 20
years 15 thank you very much thank you I
have to run thank you very much